a couple of days ago some news came out
that tesla motors may be launching
in india within the next couple of years
as
they just registered an office in the
city of bengaluru
but there are a variety of significant
challenges in actually launching
in india first of all we have charging
infrastructure
in the us itself you have to generally
map out your charging points before
setting out on long road trips
and that's when the map looks like this
in india the map looks like this
aside from this one of the largest
appeals for tesla
is through self-driving technology and
unfortunately in india
traffic rules aren't exactly always
followed and
you'll often see multiple cars in each
lane
in fact in many places there are no lane
markings
and it's up to the driver to use their
best judgment
finally we have likely the biggest
barrier which is
cost tesla's vehicles are already not
the cheapest
but when you combine this with over 100
import tax
a mid-level model 3 ends up costing over
a hundred thousand dollars
so can tesla overcome these major
obstacles
and run a viable business within india
[Music]
well starting with charging
infrastructure this is likely the
easiest obstacle to overcome
the main ingredients required to solve
this would simply be capital
and time they just completed two capital
raises in 2020
each at five billion dollars this amount
will likely be used to fund more
gigafactories
as opposed to expanding charging
infrastructure within india
but the point is that tesla is for the
most part
no longer capital constrained they've
proven consecutive profitability
throughout 2020
and their margins are only going to
improve moving forward
so capital is not the biggest concern
however time may prove to be a difficult
challenge
as we just discussed tesla will no doubt
focus on factories before focusing on
expansion efforts
as building factories is much more
beneficial to the overall company
with that being said this gives
competitors within india
a lot of time to build up an advantage
against tesla
for instance tata motors is planning to
come out with a line of electric
vehicles within the next year or two
and they are already in the process of
setting up hundreds of charging stations
so by the time tesla turns their focus
onto india
it's likely that tata will have quite a
significant advantage
when it comes to infrastructure here's
the thing the people in india
who are in the position to even afford
this car are people who likely have a
tech job
located in one of the tech hubs of india
considering that these areas
are extremely expensive most of these
individuals live in apartments or
condos with hundreds of other residents
thus
there will be very limited opportunity
to actually charge your car
in your apartment's parking garage and
many people will be forced to primarily
rely
on the charging network to actually
charge their cars on a regular basis
given this excessive demand for charging
companies like tata have no reason to
share their infrastructure with
anyone else tesla could try to get
around this problem by partnering with
indian companies like mahindra
and though there are some rumors
suggesting that this could be the case
so far these are all just rumors thus
considering the current situation it's
unlikely that tesla will have the
infrastructure lead
when they enter the indian market but
given that tesla will likely only be a
niche player in india anyways
they don't necessarily need the
infrastructure lead in order to be
successful
in india moving on we have autonomous
driving
when it comes to autonomous driving
there are two main challenges
which are of course technology and
regulation
as for technology if you were to release
a tesla on indian roads today with
self-driving on
it likely wouldn't get that far
considering the unorganized traffic
behavior
but tesla's non-reliance on hd maps and
their straightforward approach using
cameras
does make it possible that tesla can one
day achieve autonomy
even in such conditions personally i do
think tesla will be able to handle such
situations
by the end of this decade however
whether or not tesla can do it
doesn't really matter as the sentiment
against self-driving vehicles
is still quite strong within indian
legislature
in fact as recent as may 2020 the road
transport and highways ministers
straight up said quote
self-driving cars will not be allowed in
india
this rigid stance is not so much about
technological ability
as it is about job displacement the
minister has explained that self-driving
cars could put the jobs of one crore
people
or 10 million people in jeopardy it is
already expected that 23
of global job losses due to automation
will occur in india
thus the indian government has no
imminent plans to further accelerate
this trend
now tesla owners may be allowed to use
self-driving technology
privately but the robo-taxi market in
india
is basically off-limits for tesla at
this point
and that brings us on to the final
concern which is
price the cheapest tesla you can get
today without using weird loopholes
is thirty seven thousand nine hundred
ninety dollars this is the same
as 27 lakh rupees or 2.7 million rupees
generally import taxes are often well
above 100
in india in order to protect indigenous
manufacturers
but we'll call it just 100 to illustrate
how expensive this really is
as you can see the taxes would double
the price of the car to seventy five
thousand
nine hundred eighty dollars or five
point four million rupees
in india the top one percent of income
earners make seventy seven thousand
dollars per year
but just because you make 77 000 a year
doesn't mean that you should spend all
of it on a single car
in fact that wouldn't be very smart
ideally
your income would be a bare minimum of
twice the price of the car
especially if it's a luxury car so this
purchase would no doubt only be
reasonable to the upper echelons of the
top 1 percent
in india now tesla does have their 25
car coming out within the next couple of
years which with import taxes comes out
to a starting price of fifty thousand
dollars
so we'll say that the top one percent of
indians can afford it
with a population of 1.366 billion
people
the viable indian market would be about
13.66 million
people we don't exactly know how many of
these people
are interested in buying a tesla but i
think it's safe to assume that nearly
all of these people
do have nice cars and that they would be
open to buying a tesla
if tesla was able to convince one
percent of this market to buy tesla
every year that itself would pull in a
solid 136 000 cars
annually to put this in perspective
toyota makes several cheaper models
specifically aimed at india and other
asian countries
despite that though they're only able to
sell a mere 8 500 units a month
or roughly 100 000 units per year in
india
luxury manufacturers like mercedes
struggle to cross even 10 000 units per
year
but as we all know the real advantage
comes by manufacturing
in india opening a small assembly plant
within india will significantly reduce
the import taxes
down to just 10 to 15 percent and
considering that these are all evs tesla
may be able to enjoy taxes as low as
five percent
bringing the cost of the entry-level
tesla to twenty six thousand
two hundred fifty dollars now that's
still extremely expensive for the
average indian
considering that twenty six thousand to
two hundred fifty dollars is a third of
the top one percent
annual income so even with disadvantage
teslas will only be accessible to the
top couple of percent
of india nonetheless manufacturing in
india to reduce import taxes
will likely grow the market size a
couple of fold into tens of millions
but really no more than 50 million again
if we say one percent of this population
were to convert to tesla
on an annual basis tesla may be able to
get sales
up to 500 000 annually realistically
though
the number will end up in the few
hundred thousand range so
nothing like china and their 100 000
orders within 10 hours or anything like
that
however tesla isn't attracted to india
just because of their market
but more importantly because of their
talent
india is home to some of the smartest
tech workers
and it would be foolish for tesla to not
employ this talent to work under
self-driving technology
elon musk is always on the lookout to
recruit great talent
and many of tesla's events including
autonomy day and battery day
aren't so much to excite investors but
more to excite potential recruits
personally i think this is the main
reason tesla is even expanding into
india
right now tesla has plenty of demand
outside of india and their efforts would
likely be better served by simply
building more factories within the us
europe china and even australia the
truth is
in india it's likely that indigenous
automakers like tata
and mahindra will have a significant
advantage over tesla
in terms of not only charging
infrastructure but more importantly
retail price thus these companies will
likely continue to dominate the vast
majority of the indian automobile market
even if tesla were to step in and i'm
sure elon musk and tesla
are well aware of this reality it's true
that tesla can greatly improve their
chances by manufacturing
in india and this does seem to be the
plan
but even with this approach within the
indian market
it's unlikely that tesla will be able to
grow past being a niche luxury automaker
at this point in time nonetheless given
india's large population
this does amount to sizable sales of
potentially a few hundred thousand cars
per year as a result though india will
be a great addition for tesla
it will be by no means game changing
financially
where it will be game changing though is
technology
and that's the true advantage of tesla
expanding into india
do you guys agree or do you think tesla
will reach seven figure sales in india
no problem comment that down below also
drop a like if you guys are excited for
tesla's global expansion
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
you